le comité de lyon contre les violences
policières ciblés par des appels et des
courriels malveillants suite à la
publication d'un article sur la bac dans
la sphère d'arthur naceri passé à tabac
le 10 décembre 2019
depuis le collectif a déposé une plainte
en juillet 2020 les investigations
menées d'abord par le comité lui même
ont permis d'établir un lien avec des
adresses ip utilisées par le
gouvernement français la police
judiciaire de lyon ensuite pu confirmer
que l'adresse électronique appartenait à
un ordinateur du ministère de
l'intérieur
le terme d' intimidation c'est pas un
terme le joli pour le coup puisque nous
on dépose plainte pour deux
qualifications pénales qui sont lus sur
fassions d'identité et les appels
malveillants réitérés qui pour le coup
sont d'aider des points de vue du
message qu'il envoyait c'est quand même
une manière de dire on va réagir
on va passer sait faire et on va on est
prêts à utiliser tous les moyens y
compris en utilisant un ordinateur
professionnel dont on peut quand même
facilement assurer la traçabilité pour
nuire si vous estimez que on doit rendre
des comptes de manière publique
aujourd'hui un an et demi se sont
écoulés après un véritable tour de
france la procédure s'est heurté un
obstacle technique et les gal ba est ce
qu'il ya eu une lenteur particulière je
pense que oui au regard notamment du
fait que l'on n'a pas manqué de relancer
régulièrement le parquet et surtout de
lui dire attention il risque d'y avoir
une déperdition des preuves donc il ya
eu évidemment beaucoup trop de lenteur
de la part du parquet qui devait
considérer que c'était pas forcément une
priorité de traiter une affaire de
harcèlement ou d'appels malveillants
contre un comité de l'association de
lutte contre la violence policière
pour l'instant l'enquète s'arrête là les
données informatiques de la direction du
numérique du gouvernement auraient été
effacés
en raison de l'obligation légale de ne
pas les garder plus d'un an